it's a nightmare dressed like a Daydream
we know all too well as the Senate
Judiciary Committee held its hearing
Tuesday on last year's Ticketmaster
meltdown lawmakers came ready for it
with their best Taylor Swift references
are you ready for it and let's just say
there was a lot of bad blood
the puns write themselves guys yeah I'm
really annoying with puns because it's
an endless supply of them the panel's
hearing aimed at tackling consolidation
in the live entertainment and ticketing
Industries was held in response to the
whole Ticketmaster snafu back in
November which left millions of fans
unable to purchase tickets to Taylor's
eras tour a few million Taylor Swift
fans would respond this is why we can't
have nice things and while addressing
the controversy Senators dished out lots
and I'm being lots of Swifty lyrics keep
people on their toes senator Amy
Klobuchar was up first dropping a line
from Taylor's hit All Too Well to have a
strong capitalist system you have to
have competition you can't have too much
consolidation something that
unfortunately for this country as a Ode
to Taylor Swift I will say we know all
too well next up Senator Mike Lee a
ranking member on the subcommittee for
competition policy Anti-Trust and
consumer rights who quipped about Amy
the subcommittee's chairwoman using a
line from Taylor's 2008 track you belong
with me I had hoped as of a few months
ago to get the gavel back but once again
she's chair captain and I'm on the
bleachers
tonight
on the bleachers meanwhile Senator
Richard Blumenthal opted for a line from
one of Taylor's more recent chart
toppers
Master Auto look in the mirror
and say
I'm the problem it's me it's me
look what you made them do Ticketmaster
look what you just made me do the widely
anticipated hearing was called shortly
after Ticketmaster canceled a sale for
Taylor's tour when the service
experience technical glitches and what
it called historic customer demand for
seats the Grammy winner planned for 52
concerts across 18 venues with
Ticketmaster as the primary ticketer for
all but five of those shows and during a
pre-sale event on November 15th the
Ticketmaster site crashed after 14
million fans and Bots tried to buy
tickets thousands of fans who thought
they were cleared to buy tickets weren't
able to Leading some to sue Ticketmaster
the whole debacle has many calling for
Ticketmaster to dismantle critics saying
they monopolize the market for events as
for Taylor she responded to the
breakdown on Instagram back in November
writing it's truly amazing that 2.4
million people got tickets but it really
pisses me off that a lot of them feel
like they went through several bear
attacks to get them I love to do little
things that allow them to know that I
always have my finger on the pulse of
what they want and for those who didn't
get tickets Taylor said it's her hope to
provide more opportunities to be with
her fans quote thank you for wanting to
be there you have no idea how much that
means
[Music]